[Music]
imagine an alien civilizations looking
up at the night sky scanning the heavens
trying to detect signs of life we as a
species have been sending out radio
signals for about a hundred years and we
have followed that up with television
signals those signals have gone into
space and travel the speed of light and
by now have reached hundreds of stars
and hundreds of planets around them so
if there was an alien civilization in
that distance and they were pointing
their detectors roughly in our direction
they would have heard the first BBC
broadcasts and by now they would have
seen many many years of Coronation
Street and have a rough idea of how our
humanity works some very prominent
scientists think it's quite silly that
we're sharing quite so much about
ourselves to the galaxy aliens may not
be very kind and maybe we shouldn't be
giving away our position and our
entertainment choices maybe we should
all just collectively stop advertising
ourselves to the galaxy so let's say we
do go quiet could aliens still find us
so imagine that same alien civilization
looking at the night sky but now there
are no radio signals no television
signals just 300 billion beautiful white
lights quietly shining away but it is
the white light seemingly so fundamental
and pure that holds the key to unlocking
the secrets of all those planets around
all those stars white light is only pure
until you crack it open with a prism or
a drop of water white light shows what
really is within it the rainbow the
rainbow isn't just made up of seven
colors well the powerful enough prism
you can get all of the Reds and all of
the violets all of the infinite colors
between them and beyond them in the
infrared and the ultraviolet so if that
alien civilization pointed they're very
expensive prism at our Sun they'll be
able to see our Suns rainbow and if
they're very patient and look carefully
they would notice that every year a few
new shadows would appear and then
disappear when they were appear and
disappear and those shadows are caused
by the molecules in our atmosphere and
they'll be able to look those shadows in
the rainbow and know that we have an
extremely lively planet that we have
vast inhabited oceans the work oxygen
reliant life-forms that we have at least
one technological species and also that
we pollute
a lot the earth has a living atmosphere
we call that a biosphere and that
biosphere is a planet-sized
unintentional message to any aliens out
there that care to listen it tells the
story of who lives on this planet and
what we do with it so we could stop
sending messages into space but even if
we do go quiet they can still tell we're
here it's the Galactic equivalent of
thinking I'm invisible now and can we do
the same to them could we detect aliens
even if they have no radio or television
well we can already look at some alien
atmospheres although we can't quite look
at a full terrestrial atmosphere yet but
we're very close at MIT I developed the
tools to try to decipher these potential
alien biospheres those tools are how I
will be listening in to alien messages
and of course I would love to receive
the alien version of The Simpsons coming
down from the heavens until then I'll be
looking for the signs of life that the
aliens didn't even mean to create